this was one of the first towns to rise
up against the Syrian regime now Marat
alna man is on the brink of falling back
under its control streets once bustling
with people and life stand empty and
broken shattered rebel stronghold most
residents have fled as Russia backed
Syrian forces advance those still here
sound frantic we're not scared for our
belongings or our homes but our country
we're crying tears of blood over our
country we have our memories and our
people our hands are bleeding from
building trenches where are the people
where are the heroes these people are
trying to escape days of airstrikes
roads out of southern Eid Lib province
choked with traffic for many there's
nowhere to go other than these makeshift
camps young children like Ahmed left a
toddle in the cold the old left helpless
and hopeless that the year we've been
here for three days under the rain I had
to leave my medicine back at home so I'm
not able to walk so they've had to push
me around in my wheelchair the Syrian
opposition wants help to broker a
ceasefire between the Al qaeda-linked
rebels in Eid Lib and the regime the
military escalation is still ongoing and
rising we have a humanitarian crisis in
every sense of the word
Western powers like the United States
backed the Syrian uprising in 2011 but
they're not key players now president
Donald Trump no use for the families
here he's counting on Turkey to stop
Syria from killing more civilians their
fate uncertain men and boys break rocks
to fix their tents into the ground
respite for now only the most basic
Debra Haines Sky News